I'm writing every Devil's fruit in one
piece to figure out which is the best
one this is the kurikurinomi which
allows its user to control cream okay
well it was eaten by Charlotte Opera big
mom's fifth song and this Delicious
Fruit allows you to produce an unlimited
amount of sweet cream you can control
this cream to trap opponents suffocate
them in mouth-watering goop and even
Scorch them with the molten sugar
content a tasty 14 out of 25 points
defensively this fruit can be used to
make a cream-based armor that can trap
or burn enemies a scrumptious 16 points
here however it does lack any truly
special powers unless you run a candy
shop which does make it a great food for
just everyday use nine points here but
since this delectable cream can be eaten
I have to subtract 10 points for
weaknesses bringing its grand total to
an unappetizing 29 Points and leaving it
at the bottom of our list for now